question 4 what's the most significant
advancement in carbon science since the
discovery of buckyballs professor ross
at university of malaya oh that's the
tricky one in the case of the c60 the
most important aspect of it apart from
the fact that you know or something like
a thousand papers in chemistry the
chemistry of c 60 per year so it's
opened up a whole new area of fifteen to
twenty thousand papers in the last 20
years since 1990 and the most important
aspects of is that it we started to
understand bottom-up self-assembly
nanotechnology what happens when a atoms
self-assemble bottom up and we now
realize that we have to take into
account structure on a nano scale in a
way we haven't really appreciated we
should have done because it's so simple
I mean the example i have i would use is
water droplets if you have water large
amounts of offers pull flat by gravity
but if you have a small drop then
surface tension effects are more
important you get a spheroidal bubble or
not bowl but a sort of droplet sense
true of carbon if you have a small
number of carbon atoms and they're not
flat as they are in graphite or three
dimensional crystal as in the case of
diamond but as you assemble them
bottom-up certainly in the regime
between 30 and 100 or maybe even a
thousand atoms closed sir idle cages
full rings are the order of the day
they're the most stable form so if I
give you 60 carbon atoms it's not a
diamond structure or a graph I structure
I partly and won't be graford as you can
see because the edges will have dangling
bonds and that's an instability but if
you close it up you get the energy back
from the 22 to 20 or more dangling bonds
on the edge and they close up and that's
what happens in soci 60 is the more
stable form of 60 carbon atoms since
then of course
crusher and huffman showed that you
could make c60 in quite good yield and
the nanotubes were rediscovered that
some of yo Jima found that you could
make them there and they have been seen
by more noble endo some years before and
but now it was possible to make them in
high yield and now a lot of study of
nanotubes in various materials and
composite materials in particular going
to probably break through in the next
few years it's tricky because there's a
lot of has been a lot of investment in
other technologies before that but I
think in the next five years will see a
breakthrough in composite materials
involving nanotubes and of course
graphene has been detected there has
been made and people are looking at that
very carefully as well and that looks
interesting because you could probably
imagine synthesizing polycyclic large
polycyclic aromatic structures graphene
equivalents and then you could have very
good control of the molecular level of
their properties but for me the biggest
breakthrough has been that of kami and
colleagues who have detected c60 in
interstellar space in fact I I predicted
this in the horizon program in 91 or 92
oh it is something like that I had the
last word in that one and be who I was
asking me I said I think it's in
interstellar space and the announcer
said well it doesn't look anything like
that and I said well we have c6 English
done delighted I said well they're wrong
because I don't think they thought it
through I think as I mentioned in the
previous question I think c60
derivatives can have features a likely
up features similar to the diffuse
pounds and 500 have been detected not to
now so there's a lot of stuff out there
there's a lot of it around